1 pierre berthelot bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
arte france le premier ministre grec qui
annonce donc l'achat d'avions de combat
français
la présidence grecque qui seront
aujourd'hui sur une île proche des côtes
turques
comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter
tout ça sachant que l'équipe tayyip
erdogan demande à emmanuel macron de ne
pas lui chercher querelle là
effectivement il ya une montée des
tensions
d'un côté on voit se constituer un axe
entre la france la grèce et notamment
chypre donc c'est plutôt bien joué de la
france qui ment semble en passe de
vendre un nombre d'avions à la grèce
donc c'est peut-être l'explication de ce
soutien affirmé à athènes depuis
quelques semaines sinon quelques mois
pour autant la situation reste délicate
et compliquée on n'est pas certain
forcément que la france s'engagera
militairement aux côtés de la grèce dans
cette tension majeure dans cette zone
je crois que l'élément déterminant ce
sera plutôt la position des grandes
puissances internationales et notamment
des états unis et de la russie
cela veut dire ça ça veut dire que selon
ce que vous dites si j'ai bien compris
paris s'est engagé aux côtés d'athènes
simplement pour vendre ses avions rafale
et maintenant la france va calmer le jeu
d'un point de vue diplomatique pour voir
ce que vont faire les autres capitales
dans ce dossier c'est ça c'est une
hypothèse
en tout cas elle sera active au point de
vue diplomatique au point de vue
peut-être des pressions internationales
ah qu'elle pourrait essayer de mettre en
place je pense niveau de sanction par
exemple et ça c'est une chose donc une
situation de pension qui va probablement
perdurer
parce qu'effectivement la france si elle
a obtenu cet achat d'avions doit rendre
votre parti proposer quelque chose mais
de là à franchir le pas militaire c'est
une autre paire de manches
et il n'est pas du tout certain la
france s'engage militairement aux côtés
de la grèce si jamais
mais arrivé à une action mais parce que
justement est la force qui sont déjà
mobilisés dans d'autres régions du monde
et est ce que c'est qu'un pas la france
est capable de mener à un combat sur
deux fronts c'est une autre situation
difficile
vous venez de parler d'un contre par
free qu'est ce que la france pourrait
proposer justement quand je viens de le
dire est que la grèce danse et
revendique à travers les relais dont on
dispose on rappelle france et membre
permanent du conseil de sécurité à l'onu
avec droit de veto donc c'est un atout
quand même assez important
par ailleurs elle est quand même un des
pays majeurs au sein de l'union
européenne
un des pays fondateurs est quand même là
la première armée de l'union européenne
sur le papier en tout cas alors
maintenant c'est vrai que l'ensemble des
pays de l'union européenne pour
l'instant donc pas forcément suivi la
france dans cette stratégie de tension
pas plus que l'ensemble des pays de
l'otan y compris ceux qui sont membres
de l'otan en méditerranée n'ont pas
forcément suivi la france mais elle peut
avoir ce rôle d'impulsion à ce rôle de
leader en chef de la la contestation ou
de la pression maximale sur le plat
turquie c'est une possibilité
justement vous venez de parler de l'otan
c'est que la turquie fait partie de
l'otan même titre que la france ou que
la grèce
comment expliquer des tensions entre
pays membres de l'otan et jusqu'où ces
tensions peuvent-elles aller une
confrontation est elle véritablement
possible ou ou pas du tout donc dans ces
tensions effectivement elles sont pas
nouvelles
entre la turquie et la grèce
ils ont toujours été membre de l'otan et
on sait qu'il ya eu une vingtaine
d'années on est et alep dans la même
situation la limite à l'afp un militaire
on sait que la turquie bloc par exemple
la coopération de défense entre l'union
européenne et l'otan
parce que en général elles refusent la
présence des autorités militaires
chypriote lors de ces réunions
en tout cas donc l'ailé les tensions
sont pas nouvelles maintenant l'otan
c'est clair que il a vont suivre l'avis
américain le seul qui compte c'est
l'opinion américaine
qu'est ce que va faire les états unis si
effectivement les états unis à se
rallier à la position française et
grecque
à ce moment là ça peut être très
compliqué pour la turquie mais pour
l'instant les états unis bush pas donc
il était peu probable que l'otan suivent
effectivement la grèce même si sur le
principe un pays agressé jamais la grèce
de la crise et on doit en principe en
théorie soutenir un état agressé mais
encore une fois ils attendront le feu
vert de washington washington pour
l'instant et dans une certaine
neutralité voire une neutralité
bienveillante vis david ankara parce que
ils considèrent au jour d'aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas d'alternative au pilier
orientale qui est la turquie
c'est un allié inconfortable un allié
parfois indocile
mais malgré tout il reste dans le temps
ils n'ont pas rompu avec le temps et on
a pour le moment pas trouvé de substitut
il n'y a pas de pays qui est capable de
remplacer la turquie sur le front
oriental de l'otan merci pierre
berthelot d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur au centre d'études
de recherche sur le monde arabe et
méditerranéen et à l'université paris 2
panthéon assas
merci beaucoup